if subtle one did more than 150 years
ago but monuments commemorating said
confederate history still Evo promotions
about 700 protestors faced off yesterday
in New Orleans where several monuments
are being removed Michelle Miller is in
New Orleans Michelle good morning good
morning all quiet now but the battle
lines are drawn over the probable
removal this week of that monument to a
Civil War icon and others like it the
white mayor this predominantly black
town says keeping these symbols of the
Confederacy on a pedestal is out of step
with today's values of inclusion
[Applause]
opposing protesters marched Sunday to a
statue honoring Confederate General
Robert E Lee on one side of the debate
those who want the city's Confederate
monuments taken down saying they are
symbols of racism and white supremacy
the fight that we're waging is against
the city fathers who have refused to
bring about genuine equality and freedom
for the black people here on the other
side supporters of monuments who argue
they honor Southern heritage in history
we want it to stay we understand that
most of us can only be here for a day
but it's a symbolic gesture of standing
up for what we believe in the clash
comes as the city plans to remove the
statue of Lee and two other Confederate
monuments the first to go was the
Liberty Place Monument which was removed
in the middle of the night last month
citing safety concerns crews wore masks
and bulletproof vests the move sparked
protests including this violent clash
near the statue of Jefferson Davis who
served as president of the Confederacy
loser Tommy bomb smoke as the city plans
to remove the remaining monuments
tensions are high the New Orleans Police
Department confirms multiple threats
have been made toward contractors hired
by the city to take down the statues but
New Orleans Mayor Mitch Landrieu says
he's not backing down there
all of these statutes sends a clear
message an unequivocal message to the
people of New Orleans and to the people
of our nation that New Orleans
celebrates diversity mayor Landrieu says
they're using private funding to bring
these statues down Nora and eventually
they'll be placed in a museum all right
Michelle thank you so